donc on parlait des anges tout à l'heure
on sait que les gens soient là ils ont
souvent des petits problèmes de
conjugaison mais de cod on a imaginé ce
que ça donnerait si chanter ou celle qui
a les nrj music awards on s'est demandé
si la chaîne crée les nrj12 music awards
ça donnerait saraya projetant vite pas
d'aidé sur les éditions du bescherelle
présente la compil des nrj music awards
les premiers dans les charts mai dernier
dans leur classe reprêtent vos tubes
préférés
si tu sauras que l'on m'a eue fait
de tongs et ce qu'ils veulent un récent
du monde autour d'eux mais ce sera le
cas il ne sache pas
en bas
ils ne savent pas
[Musique]
on n'a plus le noirmont vita mais ça
ab3 si vous croisez dans nos artistes
offrez vous la conduisait nrj12 music
awards c'est qui
c'est kiki
toi c'est qui
le droit
[Musique]
c'est ça
bah
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]